good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday I think
we're going into week six or seven in
the q6 I think it's week six s we say
week six six I have to UM I have to
check now now I'm curious what week it
is I was thinking about it last night as
I was falling asleep I was like what
week are we entering of Q dumb okay why
just to memory of last week us saying
week five six yep we're going into week
six you know it sounds a lot shorter
than it actually was
I'm sorry we're going into week seven
sorry it's the 27th not the 20th this is
week 7 it feels like week 7 yeah I mean
once again the Ramona coaster has reared
its ugly head and I'm not sure I'm
feeling you know I'm feeling really like
tired and beat down therefore I'm kind
of glad I don't have to leave my house
sometimes like being forced to stay and
it's so fabulous and sometimes it's not
so today I'm not really mad about it but
we'll see what happens tomorrow I'm too
tired to care right now you know so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna put up a fight
today here we are in the q week six
crazy times and we were just saying how
it feels like the start time for our
show gets earlier and earlier but like
we used to do the show like we would be
done by now but my schedule is so [ __ ]
up like I was up all night I don't know
how to get back on a normal schedule
with my alarm rings for this show I wake
up like 10:15 10:30 it feels like the
middle of the night and I'm going to the
airport like going to the Bahamas you
know I it's crazy how weird my clock is
yeah and the biological clock is it's a
strange thing I watched so much TV this
week and I'm so excited to talk about it
cuz I watched some interesting things
and I look forward to sharing with the
class um but other than that it was just
you know another low-key weekend I too
have a lot to share and if anybody
thinks I'm acting weirdly on today's
show it's because I watched an entire
season of RuPaul's Drag Race and now I
talk like them you know it's like when
you hang out with your camp friends you
start talking like your camp friends
like I'm the fishiest drag queen in this
planet and you all are sickening and
you're jealous like I cannot bend
thought it was being so crazy last night
like I was just when you like listen
there's so much there's so much
they're like the Steen's like they have
their own language um but they really
like are responsible for so many words
like becoming popular like sickening
snatch like fishy isn't there yet but
it's just so interesting like to see
where it all comes from yeah so you're
I'm assuming you're enjoying it I am I
really um
it's I have a lot of thoughts and I'll
I'll get it I'll get into it at the end
which is our TV recap segment we're not
there yet
okay cool well other all I did this
weekend was watch TV so I don't really
have anything to talk about other than
the TV that I watched I um I drank about
ten white Claus I think over the course
of Friday and Saturday maybe a little
more couple I drink a lot this weekend
maybe that's why I'm feeling so blood
and like down to stay in my bed like I
literally do not get out of bed all day
yesterday I been went to the grocery
store and then he had the groceries
delivered and this woman who delivered
them was so funny like when she first
got there she was decked out masks club
another mask glove and she was like um I
can't come in the house like she was
being very very strict which I
appreciated and then she like totally
forgot about all of her rules and she
was like being so chatty she stay at my
house for another ten minutes like
talking about all the artwork
she showed me pictures of her dog her
name was Michelle she was really sweet
oh that's so nice I need to go grocery
shopping it's getting to that point
where my fridge is bare um so I'll have
to brave the store but like the stories
always pop in now and now that the
weather's nice everyone it's like oh I
think I'll go to the store and so like
the line wraps around the block because
people don't mind waiting outside
anymore you do have the advantage of not
having to be working quote unquote like
at one o'clock on a Monday so I think
you would probably have an easier time
during the weekday than you would like
yesterday going to the store Ben went to
the store yesterday on a Sunday which is
like the bravest thing you could do
everyone is just like their schedules
are off you know there's no good time
but I'll have to make the time because I
need some fresh ingredients better
ingredients better pizza
hey bake away the [ __ ] out at every
store the fact that I managed to get my
hands on three boxes during quarantine
is a miracle because yesterday Ben went
nothing you know what I got that I
haven't tried but I'm into like so many
frozen mini pizza things that I got
Totino's
hmm habit they can be quite dangerous if
you eat them too hastily I know so I
haven't tried them yet that's like a
snack thing maybe I'll try it today and
then I also got an ileus pizza because
ileus pizzas pretty bomb oh yeah that's
like standard textbook everyone tries to
you know make a new mousetrap but when
it comes down to it aleosis is good
enough actually I have a few frozen
pizzas in my freezer and I haven't had a
frozen pizza since like week two of the
queue but I think at week seven like I
think it's time yeah it's just so funny
how like my palate has changed like when
this first started I wanted like hearty
meals like ground beef ground turkey
steak chicken now it's like I cannot
stand standing in my kitchen for like an
hour making a meal like I want the
fastest thing possible yeah I used to
enjoy like the hour it took to cook um
but now I don't know I'm just eating to
live I'm like what's gonna make me the
fullest the longest so I don't have to
make the trip to the kitchen again
totally like I hate my kitchen now like
I hate everything in it I want brand-new
utensils like my pots are so ugly and
smelly like I just I can't and you know
it's like I'm actually busy like today
we have landed a pretty esteemed high
profile interview today for tomorrow's
episode and it's like I can't be running
back and forth to the kitchen when
Francesca from 2 out to handle is
waiting for me on my zoom yeah I'm
really busy today the weekdays are just
are really busy for me I have another
virtual one-on-one session with the live
method which I'm excited about
um and I'm doing my sheets today but I
tried to make my bed look normal behind
me but my sheets are in the washer so
when you wouldn't see changing of the
sheets day a changing of the guard you
know it's gonna be a busy cleaning day
because when in Rome it's a huge day
like in my house I the day I wash my
sheets I literally do not get into bed
until 10 p.m. because I was so busy yeah
so I have one of those days ahead of me
and even though I'm not looking forward
12 the work I'm looking forward to the
way I'm going to feel when it's all said
and done because I will feel
accomplished unlike how I'm feeling
right now yeah I actually I have a busy
day as well a Morecambe one of my secret
projects you know I have a few in the
air and I just I'm just so busy juggling
them that it's just sometimes I forgot
and then we have this Francesca
interview which like I'm actually
intimidated to be talking to someone
like so beautiful no say man like we
have to figure out like our zoom
interview techniques because it's gonna
be guys yeah I have a feeling it's just
gonna have to be like very
question answer a question answer yeah
yeah okay well we'll cross that bridge
with me out there we actually there is
good ass news today you guys like shits
poppin the celebrities are like tired of
being irrelevant and they're making
statements and they're doing things and
they're getting pregnant so I think it's
time it's not time because I have one
thing to say um when I sat down for my
second lunch yesterday I was just
perusing Instagram and Geoffrey star was
like I'm going live on Chris chansons
YouTube page he's a journalist and like
we're discussing something very serious
and I tuned in and I've literally never
been so confused in my whole life um
what I gathered is that like one of the
musicians back in the day when Jeffrey
was on MySpace and then he got signed by
Akon and he was doing like music tours
one of the musicians that he ended up
like going on tour with as one of his
opening acts
he's like a sexual abuser or something
of underage girls and like Jeffrey it's
like there's so many conspiracy theories
saying like Jeffrey was about Jeffrey
knew Jeffrey sauce like he went on
YouTube to like clear his name it was
just like I've never seen Jeffrey like
so defense even like in that kind of
like he doesn't he didn't have to do
that interview like he lives in his
mansion like nobody bothers him um I
thought it was like admirable that he
did it and this Kristensen who's
apparently like a legendary American
journalist who I've never heard of um
it's like on his free time like
investigating this case into da be
something I don't know it was I need to
I need someone to explain it to me
because it's so straight rain check this
whole thing Oh weird I didn't even hear
about it and in looking for stories I
also didn't hear about it it's very nice
yeah it seems that way well if you get
the tea if you get the facts let us know
I don't think anyone knows the facts
which is why it's so shady okay okay how
is it time yeah yeah okay it is time for
the five stories that you need to know
yeah yeah in the back seat of the taxi
and hopefully not hopefully at home in
the bed in the queue before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and that's true Jackie and I know you
you're feeling buzzed you're excited but
you know it's a total buzzkill on your
whole mood spam cause they totally
invade your space are super annoying and
there were the last thing you want to
deal with we've teamed up with Robo
killer to give you guys a solution to
the growing spam call problem
robo killer is the app that stops spam
calls for good they have over 1.2
million spam phone numbers on their
block list adding more spammers by the
minute in the month of February alone
robo killer blocked over 17 million spam
calls we both recently downloaded it on
our phones and we are loving it we can't
even tell you how many spam calls and
texts we used to get I must have one
like ten free cruises in trips to
Disneyland that I almost took someone up
on one time now we're living in spam
free life and getting sweet revenge in
the process they have pre-recorded
answer BOTS that mess with the spam
callers for you which are absolutely
hilarious they're literally like spam
fighting assistants our personal
favorites are the jellyfish sting and
the southern cat lady if you don't want
spammers cramping your your energy get
robo killer head to robo killer calm on
your mobile device now to download the
app new users get robo killer free for
seven days that's our OBO killer calm on
your mobile device now to get download
the app and new users can get robo
killer free for seven days now get out
there and stop those spammers again
that's Robo killer dot-com love it
honestly like spam cuz really do rain on
your parade like didn't nobody got time
for that no one it's like I always think
like I'm still fabulous like in New York
City numbers calling me who wants to put
me on the cover of Vogue and like no
it's some girl like your car insurance
like I'm a car [ __ ] rub it in okay I'm
a licensed okay first story the craziest
news I've heard in the queue Kristin
Cavallari and Jay Cutler are getting
divorced after 10 years together last
night out of what feels like no we're
both Kristin and Jay took to Instagram
posting Q photos of themselves with the
exact same statement they said with
great sadness after 10 years together we
have come to a loving conclusion to get
a divorce we have nothing but love and
respect for one another and are deeply
grateful for the years shared memories
made and the children we are so proud of
this is just the situation of two people
growing apart we ask everyone to respect
our privacy as we navigate this
difficult time within our family I have
so my thoughts like three thoughts ready
mm-hmm
like one you were just in the Bahamas
together for over a month like was that
what caused you to get divorced like it
just seems weird timing to this is just
like so crazy cuz it really like shows
you how for the most part like reality
TV is so shady like I'm such [ __ ]
like if you watch the show I actually
was watching an episode where he dropped
his phone in the river they were on this
camping trip and like yeah they're
definitely different but like it seemed
to be working and then the third is I
would love to know logistically how you
get divorced divorced or in quarantine
yeah well they're like what we're
talking about but here's some here are
some things that people magazine who had
the exclusive like statement is saying
and a source is saying so I'm gonna go
and say that it's true that their split
had absolutely nothing to do with any
cheating rumors I hadn't heard any
recent cheating rumors but I feel like
there's always cheating rumors with
celebrities also on their recent trip
they already knew they were splitting up
so here's what I'm thinking like I feel
like they're really good friends and I
also feel like they're it's always been
sort of like touch-and-go in their
relationship like are they gonna stay
together are they not but I I thought
that they just made the decision that
they were going to so and then moved on
with their lives that's why this is
really like coming out of left field now
when it seems like they're happier than
ever you know like if you watch the show
they just they have this life for
themselves and even if they're not like
the perfect match it seemed like they
were happy with the life that they had
together and that's what they were gonna
fight to keep yeah like if there was
ever a time for them to have gotten
divorced it would have been like season
one when they like looked like they had
so many problems but Jay was just like
not into being on TV and like Kristin
wanted it so bad like that's when I
wouldn't have been surprised but now
it's it's like it's all settled like why
now why this firm yeah it's it's
interesting but I feel like they
actually are good friends and what they
went on that trip they probably knew
they were separating but they're able to
just like remain good friends I'm
honestly I'm it's bittersweet but I'm
curious to see both of them mostly
Kristin single yeah like taking the
dating world by storm I'm also very
curious about um the financials of it
all because you know she's a star but I
think he's more of the breadwinner and
they just plot this like sickening six
million dollar house and buy their all
their houses that they've moved so many
times and I only know this because
people are always wanting to see what
their houses look like and somehow their
new listings always end up in the
toasters Facebook group but they always
end up moving out of the sickening house
into like a more sickening house yes so
right now they're living in like the
most sickening house their last super
sick house has it on the market for a
while and it's still not sold people
were saying maybe like Jay will move
into that house cuz they're not far
from each other which is a really nice
idea so I think the way that the money
works at least the way that they show it
on the show it's like Jay was the
breadwinner um and he has made a lot of
money but he doesn't make any money
anymore like he doesn't work he just
like you know sits around and watches
the goats on his camera and like stews
but Kristin is like a very mental
working modern woman and I think her
company's doing really well in the show
and everything so like she's doing
really well right now but I think
they're both fine I don't think like
money is really gonna be a problem
yeah but like she's working now with the
show in the jewellery line but that
pales in comparison to Jay Cutler like
what he made in just like a year yeah
but that was it like it's been a few
years since he played it's like you know
that you live off of that money it's
like on the one hand yeah I agree like
what did he have a 30 something million
dollar contract and like what you know
she it's not the same but that money
flies it does but it's my understanding
that his football money was like forever
money he played for a while yeah we I'm
just gonna look it up and buy her houses
in Nashville Nashville okay he signed
one hundred twenty six point seven
million dollar seven year contract that
included a fifty four million dollar
guarantee so I guess they'll be all
right yeah no and I'm just curious like
in Italy all right what's the prenup
button oh I don't know but I'm sure that
they have one because she was working
like she was working before and yeah
she's gonna be so amicable I think it's
gonna I just think that they are really
good friends maybe this is gonna be a
good thing maybe you don't she'll end up
needing the money and she'll join the
Hills reunion
oh no but like why would you join some
sad show when you have your own show now
here's a question for you as a very
Cavallari Stan do you think the show
will be as good without Jay yes because
the show is not about Jay he just became
like this bonus um but I think we'll be
missing something but I could also see
Jay still being on the show like if he
is living down the street and he's just
like her friendly ex-husband which is
the vibe that I'm getting but I'm sure
everybody star
Soph as a friendly axe until it turns um
then I think we could I think there's a
possibility where they really remain
friends and he's still part of the show
but if he's not it's fine the show will
take on more of like a banner pomp rules
like the drama in the store which is
already what it is but getting like a
taste of like her home life was really a
treat and now let's play our favorite
game
who-should-date-who thing can up with in
Nashville I have no idea maybe a
musician maybe a businessman beau
because I feel like now as a
businesswoman she understands like you
know that businessman beau life
maybe that's the life for her yeah and
you know in Nashville I don't really see
her hooking up with the musician because
for the most part like the big
successful older ones like are all
married that's whatever International
does like they get married and have a
million kids and the younger ones are
like 21 years old so I don't think
that's necessarily the policy should be
taking a swim in uh I don't know there's
so many I feel like we're just like
thinking of the ones that are married
but I feel like Brett Eldredge oh my god
Kristin Cavallari Brett Eldredge done
his new music is chefs kiss a fantastic
I don't even know if she likes country
music though I don't fill association um
so Jay went to Vanderbilt and for a
while like they were living in Chicago
but they met in Nashville and when Jay
was playing for Miami I think national
mean a lot more sense for them to live
there I got it and I think she really
likes it it was she was struggling she
was having a hard time making friends
and she made a friend and her friend
turned on her and she was using the show
and it's just was not nice but then
Justin DP hue moved to town with scoot
and now they have like this fabulous
foursome that's just been torn to bits
yeah those are the true victims here TPU
yeah yeah this is a sad story but you
know what I hope it's as amicable as
like I imagined it to be and how they're
saying it is this is a sad story but
these aren't sad people no no like
there's plenty of life for them after
this relationship like I'm not worried
about either one of them becoming like a
shut-in
I just it's sad you know as family you
know it may be it's you know the child
of divorce in me
but these children you know it's sad
it's sad it's sad but I think I think
we're gonna be alright we gonna be yep
that's how I feel okay next up a little
more celebrity couples news would give
you the good with the bad
Chris pad and Katherine Schwarzenegger
are expecting their first child together
ten months after getting married Chris
Pratt and Katherine Schwarzenegger Pratt
are gearing up for the next chapter in
their lives
the couple who Wed on June 8th of last
year during an intimate ceremony in
Montecito California are expecting their
first baby together multiple sources
confirm two people the bebut is on the
way the the bebut on the way will be the
gift of four goodnesses authors first
child while Pratt 40 is already a dad to
seven a half year old son Jack well
seven and a half this article is so
specific whom the actor shares with ex
whites and a ferris you know this is
actually a similar situation it's like
when they got divorced it was like so
amicable so amicable ceramic well and
even now it's like fine allegedly but
it's like SATA Ferris has to hate
Catherine towards nature she has to or
else she's not human yeah I don't think
it's the same situation because there
was there's something about like Chris
Pratt and Anna Faris at the time where
they were just like you know the
pinnacle like love and quirky celeb
relationships and we love him and we
love her and blah blah and like they're
so in love
whereas with Jay and Kristin Cavallari
was they I've just always gotten like a
really good friendship and respect vibe
and like oh we are so gonna we're also
gonna start a family
but like every day we wake up and decide
that that's what we want to do you know
if you're not just like we fell into it
and we can't get up but I'm saying the
similarity is like it was so amicable
when they divorce and even like after he
started doing they had and there's if
she went out much Oh Catherine no she
went on my trapeze live and she was not
well so that's what I'm saying like I
feel like maybe not now but in a few
years like we will see like some sort of
resentment like crack between Chris and
Cavallari and Jay Cutler and I just I
refuse to believe that like everything
is so perfect with Chris Pratt and and
his first and second lives so you never
hear but I think
no I never thought things were perfect
with Chris Pratt and Anna Faris but I
actually do think they're perfect as
perfect as one come be with Catherine
Schwarzenegger like these two are just
like they are like a vacuum yet is that
affairs of a boyfriend not a famous one
yeah um it's just like it sucks like
when the person that you were married to
like a moves on so fast and that when
you're in the public eye like becomes
like this sweetheart like they're
literally like the face of like Jesus
Christ like they're like he's good
Christian like everything they do is
perfect she writes a book about
forgiveness it's an ear times I cellar
like everything we do is so [ __ ]
perfect and like waspy like how can a
nefarious not despise Catherine towards
maker she's a little II don't mind
saying I'm not saying she doesn't I'm
not saying she should this is happy news
Anna speaking of interesting first and
second wives um I was watching Lala Kent
stories like a week ago and she was
laying in bed with amber um
Lala's ex-wife they were like
hysterically laughing about something
and I just thought it was so weird like
do you remember a year ago where so the
mom
Randall's first wife you didn't explain
that um you said Lala's first wife
oh sorry Randall swear sighs first wife
was lying in bed with Lala like a year
ago they had all this trauma where he
very publicly the mother of Randall's
kids was like begging a lot of stop
posting them on Instagram while I kept
posting them on Instagram like was very
tumultuous now they're lying in bed
laughing okay love to see it
things continue this show interesting I
didn't even see that they and you know
what it was I thought it might have been
Randall's daughter cuz like she looked
so young and they were like laughing
laughing nothing and then she turned her
head I'm like all right that's the mom
that's wild and yeah you know what it
doesn't surprise me how could you not
eventually come to love ah I can't and
you know when you're in LA like aunts
position like I'm sure really all you
want is for the woman to like you yeah
like that like the first wife doesn't
have to like the second wife but it's
nice for the second wife to be liked by
the first wife yeah of course
especially when there's kids involved
you feel like that adds a whole other
layer yeah otherwise it's like by I
literally never see you again first wife
right okay you ready for our next story
some exciting news sure some exciting
real estate news because it's clear that
Kylie Jenner has been watching the toast
and realized that her home was not
suitable for a billionaire [ __ ] dropped
thirty six point five million dollars on
a new house and it's sickening kylie
jenner might be in quarantine right now
but she still has time to expend her
property portfolio the Kylie cosmetics
founder has reportedly just purchased a
brand new home in Holmby Hills
California the property cost thirty six
point five million dollars and according
to people the massive compound boast
seven bedrooms and fourteen bathrooms
it even has twenty parking spaces for
Kylie's several luxury cars I mean this
is weird for two reasons one because we
were just talking about how Kylie's like
home is so humble
I mean like loved that about her she's
just a regular girl but it's clear that
she's not maybe she heard us and she did
not want to be referred to as a regular
girl and the second thing that's so
weird is that this is in Holmby Hills
it's like 30 minutes away from Calabasas
it's like in the center of Los Angeles
really I was like I didn't want to
really do like a Google map search
because I just wanted to assume it was
like down the road from her old house
when she's not living is in Hidden Hills
like no yeah I was like oh she's in the
hills yeah know it so I mean it's not
been made clear whether or not this is
like an investment property or she's
gonna live there I have to assume that
she's gonna live there also the like
developer and owner of the house slash
land is the same person who Kylie bought
a house slash property from in Palm
Springs so it's obvious that Kylie's
like a fan of his work interesting also
this is just my detective work Kylie's
been posting some photos just like
around her house in the queue and I'm
pretty sure that some of the photos are
taken at this new house because if you
look if you look behind her there's like
an outdoor TV fireplace situation
obviously a lot of places have that but
it looks identical to the outdoor TV
fireplace in the photos that the realtor
posted yeah and I guess I saw her post a
photo of her Christian er got her that
dream house for stormy but I
that could be anywhere they could move
it no I don't think she's living there
yet but like she might be going back and
forth it might be fun to have two houses
in the queue so like when you're
quarantined one week here one week
they're like switching it up for the
kids I mean that's just I'm so nice like
I I love Kylie and I'm not in any way
shading her like if I thought she was
being humble that's cool but now she
wants to not be humble and I think
that's fabulous too
yet no honestly it was it's not even
about being humble like it was just time
we happened to notice at like the peak
of her billionaire status and also we
were just watching her on a show and we
were just saying like she she has a
kitchen and a foyer in a living room in
an upstairs like she just has a house um
and she obviously realized that too so I
think this house is sweet chariot where
it's gonna be like an investment no I
think she's gonna live there it looks
like a home it doesn't look like flip it
like Disick's sort of property it looks
like a house but also apparently she got
a really good price for it because it
was on the market for forty five million
dollars so Christian a real estate
broker she she got a ten million dollar
discount I mean it's probably a good
time to buy right now interest rates are
low yeah and maybe because she knew this
developer from Palm Springs like they
gave her a two-for-one deal ah maybe
yeah maybe I don't know that's how it
works with 50 million dollar homes but
yeah this is so fabulous oh it was a
BOGO yeah I can't wait to see the
content the outdoor I can't wait to see
Stas you know like living it up in the
second bedroom I'm just I'm excited
forever on this this sounds so exciting
and then I get content so I can only be
pleased with that yeah this is exciting
all around and you know what I hope just
Kylie the YouTube where comes out to
play and like gives us a house tour I
mean that will never happen but we'll
probably get an Architectural Digest
spread in like a year yeah even if it's
not a house tour even if it's like a
three rooms in my house tour or even if
it's literally just her snapchatting in
the new house but you know what I
honestly loved the decor of her old
house like remember her dining room
table with the hombre chairs and all the
butterfly pictures like sickening I'm
excited to see what she does with this
new house
I feel like her old house was so homey
and I feel like that sometimes happens
to celebrities where they're living in a
house where they're so comfortable and
then they obviously like get too big for
their britches and they need to get a
bigger house and they move to this
bigger house and it's just like not
homey
they don't feel like they're home and I
think like as much as she's probably out
of all the sisters like the least
reliant on the sister connection like
she invest so much in her friendship she
hangs out with her friends more than she
hangs out with her sisters I do think
living 30 minutes away is like not gonna
be good I think she'll realize quick um
that she wants to go home I'm sure she
thought about it though
or me are you sure it's 30 minutes like
with traffic or without I mean there's
so much traffic in LA that's what TMZ
said 30 minutes close to the center of
LA which also makes me think like maybe
Carly's gonna be going out more like
maybe didn't want to go to clubs every
day when they have to take a 90 minute
drive home to Calabasas oh no not
distance from Beverly Hills distance
from home be Google that's the new place
to be okay I'm going about 29 minutes
you're right I know that's know you're
right sorry it sounds like not a lot but
they're all used to living in the same
gated community like it's a lot yeah
except you know who doesn't Kendall
where does Kendall is she used to not
but she bought a house I think she
finally returned to the manor
interesting okay so you know what maybe
no I don't think it's an investment
property because look at her picture
she's like sodding around on the bed it
was probably like during one of the
house where she was probably like
walking around with a contractor or
something but she was like stop and take
some pictures of me and it looks nice
you know what's so crazy though is that
the house is probably staged that's not
real furniture like it's staged and it's
literally so sickeningly designed like I
would take that furniture I would buy
that front of that house furnished in a
second it's like Kylie's not gonna keep
one [ __ ] thing I know how we would
buy it in a second cuz we're lazy and we
like weirdly don't know how to design a
house but this is Kylie specialty you
know the whole family is really so glad
it you have to wait like a whole year
before you can move in well she has her
old place I like chill she'll be in and
out yeah this is good for me yeah no
it's it's exciting period but this next
story is really funny and I'm ready to
get to it are you
is it the one brought to you by daily
burden obviously the gyms are closed
right but you want to stay active and
get fit sign up for daily burn at daily
burn calm and give at home workouts to
try for 30 days it's totally free if
you're looking for motivation daily burn
professional trainers have plenty to
spare if you hate training alone you can
join a group session every weekday
there's a program that fits your needs
and fitness levels get your 30 day free
trial
sign up at daily burn dot-com Get Fit
have fun repeat with daily burden and if
you want the 30 days free you have to go
to daily burn com / toast that's Dai ly
bu r n dot-com / toast
check it out Jackie and I have had the
privilege of using it for about a month
now and you really can't have enough at
home workouts because we're gonna be
here for a while
you really can't have enough I have been
not only like switching it up every day
I'm doing something different I love
incorporating daily burn into my routine
now
but at some times I'll do like two in
one day because I have nothing but time
and then I feel so good after like I
just work out so many different parts
like I just got an email from daily burn
and they have it like a yoga class that
looks so good so I love to do like
something that's strength training and
then low key and then it's two hours
later and I'm like oh my god it's time
for dinner
yeah anything to fill up the time
between your first and second dinner
exactly okay next story celebs are being
hounded to drop in on zoom' happy hours
first it was the autograph that it was a
selfie now page six is told that the
ultimate fan trophy is getting
celebrities to drop in on their zoom
happy hours industry insiders say that
stars are being inundated with requests
from quarantined admirers who want them
to surprise their friends and we're told
some stars have agreed to make a quick
appearance for example we're told cheeky
O'Neal and David Spade have both been
hounded to make digital drop ins I've
seen so many people but in fact it's
become such a trend that industry
industrious insiders have been
considering setting up a service like
cameo where stars are paid to send video
messages for wrangling celebs for zoom
calls yes I've heard that too it like
there's now an economy of companies
whose job it is like to create digital
platforms like zoom or like digital
meet-and-greets because that's the world
we're gonna live in for a little while
and actually think it's really smart I
think people would want that outside of
like quarantine also yeah and I think
like maybe
assume happy hours like where we started
but I think we can be thinking bigger
about how we could like be virtually
communicating with our favorite celebs
one-on-one or like a lot on one but I
thought this was just really funny
because celebrities like we're just
dropping into people zoom calls um but I
don't understand how they got there I
people DM them on Instagram like hey
join our zoom here's the meeting ID he
said here's a password yeah I get a lot
of those too
I'm not like zoom like I can't get on my
computer like in time by the time I see
them they're over well so I um I have
joined a few and I just feel like my
personality really doesn't come through
on a zoom and then I feel weird I'm like
wearing no makeup and like literally
nobody knows way I'm gonna take somebody
10 minutes to realize that I'm there and
after that embarrassment I think I'm
done yeah I don't know it's just like
maybe if I was like in zoom mode you
know and I was like zoom in a lot I
could go as you know if I was you me oh
but when I'm just like in my bed and I
see like someone sends me something it's
just I feel like I'd be like crashing
the party
I guess that's behind ya but then you
know I was gonna say something mean but
I want mmm sweet okay are you ready
perfect and final story because it's
[ __ ] hilarious
course Kanye West bickers with Forbes
via text / billionaire status Forbes
magazine has finally confirmed Kanye's
billionaire status but according to the
musician they still shorted him on his
actual net worth editors at the Money
Magazine claim West took issue with his
published 1.3 billion dollar estimate
texting staffers that apparently Forbes
doesn't know how to count that his net
worth is actually closer to 3.3 billion
dollars okay I don't really care if it's
one point three or three point three
like the fact that Kanye's a billionaire
when just a few years ago he was like
drowning in debt is really admirable but
it's also really sad that like he became
a billionaire before Kim who literally
yeah that's true I can't believe he's a
billionaire and I actually I believe him
that it's three point three why would he
like go out of his way he's been saying
for a while but he like I feel like just
Forbes is just behind in counting
people's money
you know like there
just behind well net worth isn't
necessarily how much money you have in
the bank so there is a formula it's not
how much money you have yeah I know so
it's like there's a formula to adding up
all the value of your companies your
properties like everything you own all
your investments your liabilities um so
I feel like nobody even really knows
even the person like I feel like he
wouldn't even know what his real net
worth is like no his big ewis term yes
it is but I feel like he knows what he
has going on like present day and what
it's worth and Forbes like especially
cuz a lot of the things that he does you
probably don't think it's gonna be like
worth this much but I guess it's it's
subject to people's opinions of what you
think something is valued at but I think
that he's worth even more than they said
what would you value Sunday service at
like it's a company like you can't like
it's has an insane value but but like I
think to Forbes that's not a tangible
item they probably wouldn't really put a
valuation on it because they don't
generate that much money yeah like to
have some merch and they've done a few
shows like that's not really in terms of
Forbes is like binary way of thinking
like that's not a viable business but
also like Kanye's doing stuff with like
planned community something that we
haven't like people haven't seen a lot
of but he's been talking about it for a
while so I'm sure he knows what that's
gonna be and what that's gonna be worth
whereas like a writer at Forbes does it
yeah I mean I'm just happy he's a
billionaire like I hated when Kanye was
poor it was so sad for him yeah I'm
really like he's doing really well and
he's being hilarious about it and Forbes
doesn't know how to count Forbes doesn't
know what account he was also recently
on the cover of GQ in like a mini
tractor that looked like something like
from pee-wee Herman and he looks cute
in Wyoming oh yeah that was the one
where he was wearing a tank it was in a
tank yes sorry he was entertaining
yeah it was like a mini I don't even
know what it was it was like you know
those cars we used to have when we were
kids that were like real versions but
like many of real cars it's like that
for like a tractor he was like the car
the van vehicle that he was riding in
that video for
fillet you know when they all up to the
mountain yeah I think so it was like a
mountain motor like a tank the tank okay
a tank yeah he was in a tank okay that
was what the headline was oh but you're
not remembering we had this conversation
where I was like the headline was
Kanye's in a tank on the cover of GQ and
I was like wait that's not a tank top
you know I wouldn't you know maybe
that's because I wouldn't consider that
a tank I would consider it more a
tractor oh my god it's so okay mmm I
don't know I don't know we're not car
people oh okay
are you ready for our TV recap I have so
much to talk about
is it the TV recap segment that's
brought to you by story worth yeah oh it
is okay because story worth makes it
easy and fun for your mom to share her
stories with weekly email story prompts
questions you've never thought to ask
and at the end of the year your mom will
get her stories bound in a beautiful
hardcover book you can strengthen your
family's bond and grow closer to your
mom with every news story story Werth is
a great way to stay in touch with family
and helps bridge Geographic distance by
providing lively discussion topics you
can pass on stories and life lessons to
your children and their future families
you can also invite family and friends
to receive your loved one stories learn
more about your relatives and things you
may not know about them the weekly
questions elicit entertaining surprising
and sometimes moving responses and after
a year your loved ones stories are
uploaded and shared and bound into a
beautiful keepsake book shipping is
totally free you can email your loved
ones story worth subscription directly
to them so they can access and activate
their account at any time whether you
schedule the email in advance or share
immediately it's the perfect gift when
you can't go shopping or meet in person
um this is fabulous if you have a parent
Mother's Day is coming up or someone in
your life who's not super
technologically savvy and you want to
get this for them as a gift it's really
easy because you totally set it up send
it to them that they'll get prompted
every week to contribute and I just love
I love digital things that like come up
with a physical product I think it's
like so sweet and in Dane age where like
material items are just no longer
existing it's like so nice to get a book
of love you know yes it's a beautiful
idea another day is approaching even
though like we don't have a concept of
timing you might not realize it this is
a great idea
we're here to remind you this online
service helps your loved ones share
stories and thought-provoking questions
about their memories and personal
thoughts it's the gift of spending time
together
wherever you live give your mom or the
person in your life the most meaningful
gift this year with story words get
started right away without the need for
shipping by going to story worth dot-com
slash toast you'll get 10% off your
first purchase that's story worth sto ry
wor th dot-com slash toast for the $10
off it's a really meaningful gift for
Mother's Day coming up or someone you
love so make sure to check it out love
it that's a really great gift I yeah
okay um I watched so much stuff I would
love to discuss cuz Friday night I watch
the show Waco on Netflix it's like a
limited series sorry in Tim Riggins as a
quote-unquote cult leader but the show
is really good it's a story of what
happened in Waco in the 90s a story that
I did not know about and I was saying on
my Instagram story like this show is
like really crazy I'm not gonna spoil
the end but you should watch it and
people were like it's the truth story
you can't spoil it and it was like even
though it's a true story I didn't know
the ending and I enjoyed watching it so
much more because I didn't know the
ending and I was truly in shock so no
I'm not going to tell you how it ends if
you don't already know because that is
considered a spoiler thank you for
proving my point about the time we were
in Utah and Olivia spoiled the jimmy
hoffa irishman thing for me and she was
like it's history you know yeah I mean
maybe I it's on me that I've never heard
of what happened at Waco I don't know
where I would have heard any except like
I literally was a history major and I
studied American history and it never
came up once and that's that's on the
education system yeah on the first time
the the first time I heard of what
happened in Waco and and parts of this
story are from a book I read last week
and the one I was talking about educated
about the Mormons in where I'm like they
were super religious in Idaho and like a
couple of the things that I saw about in
this show were spoken about in the book
but
other than that never heard of it yeah i
weirdly have only known about the
incident from Waco because I'm like such
an investor in chip and Joanna Gaines
it's like whole career and a lot of the
talk about why they're so successful and
considered so major in Waco Texas is
because they took the name wait go back
for the last 20 years people have
associated wake up with just like major
tragedy of this like cult or whatever um
and that's like when you think of Waco
you think of that it's similar to how
when you think of like
whatever another place like you
associate it with like this tragic thing
if it's not a well-known place like Waco
and now when people think of Waco they
think of like the great property values
in cheap and Joanna and the silos and
like all the great stuff they do so
that's why I knew about the Waco
incident and like it's weird cuz I don't
know anything but I did know about that
and I never saw this show but it's a
[ __ ] horrible story
it's a [ __ ] horrible story people
should watch the show the show was
really well done um obviously you know
like any bit of historic recollection
and has its biases but I think I think
they did a really good job I think it's
such an it's an important horrible story
one that I had never heard and I'm glad
that I watch it I thought all the actors
did a really good job it was just so
crazy like I still can't I can't stop
talking about it I'm like trying to get
everyone to watch it because I'm in
shock
yeah well we stand Tim Riggins and we
support him and all of his acting
endeavors and it really like makes you
question the term cult in general like
um I actually I was reading some stuff
about Waco afterwards and I found some
really pertinent quotes about cults I
mean I don't know if this is the time or
place but it's just like the term cult
is really like a judgment term I mean
look at us right anyways uh highly
highly highly recommended it felt good
to like watch something smart and true
because like I was learning something as
opposed to yesterday when I spent the
entire day watching descendants one
descendants two descendants three and
then zombies one and zombies two
fabulous honestly it was really fabulous
I had never seen the zombies um duo
before but it's really good it's the
same cloud as descendants but it is a
good film um I actually did something to
frame because you know I like you I will
watch if I've seen descendants like I'll
watch it every day like I never like
watching their stuff because I just I
can't take it on but I've been meaning
to like get into RuPaul's Drag Race like
the fact that I'm not a part of it like
I like to call myself an ally of the gay
community like honestly it's just
homophobic that I don't watch it so I
decided to watch it and Kyle who is a
fabulous toaster he kind of gave me like
the rundown and what seasons I need to
watch because part of the reason why I
never watched it it's like there's so
much content and like it's intimidating
and like I don't know so he told me the
seasons that I needed to watch
all of season five yesterday and it's
really like such a fabulous show and
it's really interesting to see like this
season aired like a while ago now like
Nicki Minaj everyone comes on as guests
but they could not get a guess if they
tried back in the day like literally the
most famous person camille Grammer eyes
again they loved her and by the way they
totally love and respect housewives and
they like have so many housewife
references like one of the guys was
deciding whether or not to go as Katy
Perry for the snatch game or as Cameron
Wescott like they really appreciate the
housewives so that's why I loved it and
I just feel like it really shows how
drag is such an art like the entire show
I could not figure out who was who
because they transform themselves so
much and then you get to know their
characters Alaska but then he takes off
all his makeup and I literally couldn't
recognize him like it's so confusing and
there's like 15 contestants but there's
really 30 because they both look they
all look two different ways so I had a
really hard time in the beginning
figuring out who was here but then they
weed out the nobodies and it's really
all about like like four or five people
and so with this specific season like
spoiler alert hey jinkx monsoon won and
I felt like it was a really interesting
choice it was a very very talented group
of people but then it's like when they
whittled it down to the bottom three
look I didn't think any of them should
win and I wasn't sure if it was like
didn't did someone get left behind
because the thing is and that's what I
learned it's like in order to be like
America's next drag superstar
you have to have it all like you have to
have the glamour obviously but then you
have to have like the acting chops the
singing chops the lip-synching chops the
performing chocolates and the comedy
chops like comedy is such a part of drag
and there's pageant girls in drag queen
who have like done pat the pageant
circuit and they're like not that funny
but they're like beautiful and then
there's like the club girls who are like
their drag is like kind of messy but
they're like so funny and personable and
I just felt like of the three girls that
it ended up with a lack so Alaska Roxie
Edwards no Roxxxy Andrews and jinkx
monsoon like I didn't think any of them
really had every single it factor and
jinkx monsoon was the one who like had
most of it but her glam was awful like
every time she was on the runway she
looked like beetlejuice with her striped
tights like she was just not bringing
like the
that I needed her to bring and she was
also like bullied the whole time and she
was like really very much like she was
narco she was a narcoleptic Jewish drag
queen so she was falling asleep in the
workroom all the time and when she said
she was the narcoleptic she was drag
queen like I made me like her from the
beginning but hey Clem was just like her
whole shtick is that she is a drag queen
in the 70s so everything she does is
like 70's vibes so like they had a whole
thing it was like sweet 16 and all the
girls dressed like [ __ ] 16 year olds
like with purses and flip-flops it was
somebody James monsoon comes out in like
a long lace dress like she does her glam
was so bad but she should have won
because like they couldn't have given it
to Roxy she was bullying jinkx the whole
time and it's like the thing about the
show is like it's so funny and it's like
so camp but it's also very earnest like
they really open up about like the
struggles of the LGBT community so
you're like laughing and crying and it's
such an important show for so many
people and they just like couldn't give
it to like the [ __ ] drag queen she was
really bullying everyone so it teeters
on like being like a culturally
important and like sad show and also
being like the most important fabulous
show ever it just it really tickles all
the senses and it's really really good
I'm gonna watch a whole other season
today because it's important as Bruce
says to know your history and I have to
go back I think when watch she's into
you and then Allstars it was just really
good and by the way the graphics like
it's such a weird thing to say but I
watched so many reality shows and I
compared them most of Project Runway
there's like a challenge every week and
then there's a runway but the challenges
are so much more well thought out and
they're really tests like if you can
have it all like in order to be a drag
queen like you have to be you have to be
everything like you would want to be a
triple threat you have to be like a five
time threat like dance sing lip-synch
comedy glamour yeah so glad you I did I
did I really feel like Roxy Edwards if
she wasn't Roxxxy Andrews if she wasn't
such a [ __ ] she could have won because
they couldn't have made America's next
drag superstar a bully and she was about
Lea sometimes feel that well my psyche
for you now you have so much content to
watch I know and then was like
channeling like auntie like a mix it up
oh that's so funny I started another
show last night um I don't know if
you've never watched it virgin river on
Netflix
have you heard of it hmm it's one long
hallmark movie but it's a series and
it's like a little bit more like not
risque but like just you know there's
some [ __ ] happening um it's good it was
like boring and slow but that's what I
was in the mood for a lot of people said
it was really good snitch should watch
it it's based on a book and I'm feeling
it
I'm feeling it you're feeling wonder
what's gonna be next for me I still
didn't watch money high season four yeah
because I'm saving that like for the
most four day of my life um but I don't
know after Waco is just opened me up to
all these possibilities was Waco on
Netflix yes I just love a historical
limited series it's like I'm not trying
to go eight seasons with this but six
episodes sure yeah and if it's historic
like you know they have to end it
sometime because like history stopped
you know yes and then you can like you
can like look up all the characters and
see where they landed so it was it was
really interesting I haven't watched
something good like that in a while
that was the hardest part about watching
um drag race so late it's like I wanted
to look up the girls I can see their
glam on Instagram but I knew if I did I
might spoil it so I couldn't and then
like I was up till 3:00 in the morning
like on people's instagrams because I
wanted to see finally and then it's like
when jinkx monsoon one in the ocean or
Instagram like it really made me
question her like her Instagram was
really sad and bad and like her blurry
selfies oh [ __ ] yeah like that's not the
face of RuPaul's Drag Race I'm sorry
also what's craziest so I watch Dom be
starring meelo Manheim you know him he
won Dancing with the Stars and his mom
was in Waco so it just really come full
circle his mom he's like friends with
the Kardashians and that's how they were
all tweeting for him to vote for vote
for him on Dancing with the Stars like
that's how he got the Kardashian support
so so like the other week Snitch sent me
a photo of me Lo and his mom because I
guess he took her as his date to
something and she was like oh my god
that's his mom and I was like who are
these people I don't know him
I don't know her then come yesterday she
was like so that's why when I said
that's me Ella's mom I was like still
who is she and then I looked her up I
was like wait I know this woman how do I
know her like I was just
miss her I looked her up she was in Waco
his Melissa Benoist in Waco yes yeah I
thought so she's so she does a really
good job she does a really good job
it's a they do I wonder if anyone came
out in 2018 so I wonder if anything from
the show was nominated for any award I
do feel like Tim Riggins should have
been nominated he played like a very
convincing David crash is it a Netflix
original unclear hmm
I've been really I've been saying like
everything I've been wanting to watch it
on Hulu all of the RuPaul seasons are on
Hulu and I just [ __ ] hate it like any
time I get up to go ahead a snack it
takes me back to the pilot I know I've
said it a million times I'm hoping
someone on the IT team at Hulu will
[ __ ] hear me and my connection error
like I don't know any problems with any
bucks any Hulu yeah
can whoo there's just like has amnesia I
know but they really have the best slate
of content in my opinion right now
speaking of I need to finish little
fires everywhere but it's a I don't want
to finish it because then it's over
really I'm probably if we're not gonna
recap it like I'm probably not gonna
finish it the last two episodes were so
bad and I would have let go earlier if
it weren't for us recapping it on the
show like it was really disappointing
and honestly I don't wanna keep
supporting it I want them to think that
they did a good job well the problem is
is that it's because the book was bad
that's what I'm saying they did a fight
they made it better than the book but
the book was not enjoyable I gave it a
two point five on the redheads sorry
yeah yeah that's low yeah that's low and
so it's like why would you make a two
point five into a show I can give you a
bunch of fives totally um that's all I
watched pretty much I really just drink
the rest of the weekend so I'm gonna
watch some more RuPaul this weekend and
then I'm gonna join the RuPaul Toaster
group I just didn't want to joining yet
because anyone spoilers 100% that sounds
I love that journey for you truly like
I'm very excited that you have this like
new direction and purpose like you're
you're the new directions yeah and then
I've really been thinking of ways I can
incorporate a lot of like the the fishy
vibes from drag like into my stand-up
because it's just gonna like become a
part of me I have a feeling like I think
I'm actually gonna become a drag queen
love to see it and
you know I pretty much wear as much
makeup as some of the girls so it's fine
love it oh my god Bell just rang I
wonder who's here anyways I gotta jet
bye applause thank you so much for
listening to the morning to us I'm among
hmm thank you so much for listening to
the morning to us the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be down so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public my
already cast box other places so ever
you listen to podcast find us the Marny
joseline five star view about a
beautiful setting in smart we are we
love you guys very much we will see you
tomorrow with Francesca farrago from too
hot to handle on Netflix bye